Bonjour à tous
Quelque chose me dit que cette vidéo va faire plaisir à beaucoup beaucoup de monde
parce que ça fait très longtemps qu'on me réclame une vidéo sur Spinoza
ça fait plusieurs mois peut-être, même plusieurs années qu'on me dit, mais quand est ce que tu vas nous faire une vidéo sur Spinoza?
Alors j'ai pris mon temps
j'ai repoussé
et j'ai repoussé autant que possible parce que Spinoza
c'est un monument de la philosophie et
on ne s'attaque pas un monument de cette envergure
sans s'y être un petit peu préparé
et j'espère que cette vidéo sera à la hauteur de vos attentes
Alors Spinoza fait partie de ces auteurs très difficiles à aborder pour la simple et bonne raison
que
son système philosophique se veut un système de la totalité
pour le dire autrement
l'ambition philosophique de Spinoza
c'est ni plus ni moins que de nous expliquer
dieu ou la nature car pour lui ces deux choses se confondent
dieu ou la nature c'est à dire la totalité de ce qui est
et vous comprenez bien que traiter de la totalité dans une vidéo sur youtube c'est forcément un petit peu délicat
Donc je vais me prêter à l'exercice
en vous demandant par avance de l'indulgence
Et pour parer cette difficulté
cette vidéo se voudra une introduction
à la pensée de Spinoza et non pas un exposé exhaustif
de sa philosophie
Alors d'abord quelques éléments biographiques parce que vous allez voir Spinoza c'était quand même un sacré bonhomme
Spinoza philosophe du XVIIe siècle
Juifs portugais émigrée aux pays bas
Philosophe très controversé pour
ses positions en matière de religion
il faut savoir que Spinoza a été excommuniée par la communauté juive
et qu'il a même subi une tentative d'assassinât
Et d'ailleurs on notera que celui qui a tenté de tuer Spinoza a essayé de le poignarder
et
spinoza à conserver le manteau percée du poignard
de son assaillant
jusqu'à la fin de sa vie
Spinoza qui a publié son oeuvre principale : Éthique
en 1677 soit deux ans après sa mort
parce qu'il était parfaitement conscient
qu'une telle oeuvre de son vivant
aurait pu lui valoir le bûcher
Spinoza était le genre de philosophes qui n'hésitait pas à tailler dans le vif et qui ne prenait pas de pincettes
alors on va voir
concrètement en quoi les positions philosophiques de spinoza
était pour l'époque totalement novatrice voire révolutionnaire
mais avant ça il va falloir que je plante un peu le décor
Alors Spinoza est connu comme étant le principal opposant de Descartes à la même époque
opposant entre guillemets parce qu'en réalité
Spinoza ne rejette pas tout du corpus cartésien
mais il s'oppose à des cartes sur un point absolument fondamental
à savoir que là où Descartes
était un dualiste, c'est à dire quelqu'un qui établissaient une séparation entre la matière et l'esprit
entre l'étendue et la pensée
pour Spinoza remet les choses n'étaient pas aussi nettement séparés
et Spinoza était une sorte de précurseur de ce qu'on a appelé le monisme
c'est à dire l'idée qu'on ne pouvait pas dissocier le corps et l'esprit
Depuis Platon cette séparation ontologique entre le corps et l'esprit
était considéré comme une sorte d'évidence
une évidence qui épousait très bien la vision chrétienne
basée sur un ici bas le monde de la matière
et un au delà
le monde de l'esprit
or pour Spinoza
cette distinction
n'a pas lieu d'être
Car en réalité
le corps et l'esprit Spinoza
ne sont que deux attributs
d'une substance unique qu'il appelle dieu
ou la nature
Alors pour bien comprendre cette idée du monisme
de Spinoza
bien je vais recourir à quelques exemples
Je vais prendre l'exemple du cannabis, alors le cannabis pour ceux qui connaissent
ça provoque une altération des capacités psychiques, une altération de ce qu'on appelle l'état de conscience
Si vous préférez quand on a fumé du cannabis
on pense différemment
on voit les choses différemment
Mais en même temps
fumer du cannabis ça provoque aussi une altération des capacités physiques
Allez faire un combat de boxe, allez faire une séance de musculation
Après avoir fumé un joint
Vous allez voir que c'est pas la même limonade
ça devient très compliqué
Et à partir de cet exemple on comprend assez bien finalement que une altération psychique
s'accompagne inévitablement d'une altération physique
et qu'en réalité ces deux dimensions, la dimension spirituelle et la dimension matérielle
Sont en interaction
On ne peut pas les séparer, on ne peut pas les différencier comme s'il s'agissait de deux choses indépendantes
Quand on a fumé du cannabis
on est mou
et cette mollesse
elle ne se pose pas la question de savoir s'il y a une différence entre le l'esprit
elle contamine les deux dimensions
elle contamine le corps et l'esprit
de manière indifférenciée
C'est ce qui a amené certains commentateurs à décrire la pensée de Spinoza comme un parallélisme
Parallélisme du corps et de l'esprit, de l'étendue et de la pensée
Alors on reparlera de cette distinction entre le corps et l'esprit dans une prochaine vidéo
mais comme je l'ai dis la philosophie de Spinoza est une philosophie de la totalité
et pour cette première vidéo je ne souhaite pas
affronter directement cette question
je souhaiterais plutôt l'aborder sous un autre angle
la plupart des philosophes offrent de nombreuses prises
pour pénétrer leur pensée
et chez Spinoza c'est plus difficile, les prises sont plus rares
mais j'ai essayé d'en dégager une
pour la vidéo d'aujourd'hui
Je disais que chez Spinoza on ne retrouvait pas le dualisme Cartésien, on ne retrouvait pas cette séparation
d'origine platonicienne entre le corps et l'esprit
Mais cette vision moniste a une conséquence extrêmement concrètes
c'est la vision qu'avait Spinoza de la liberté
car pour Spinoza
la liberté
c'est une illusion
Alors avant d'expliquer pourquoi la liberté
selon Spinoza est une illusion
il faut déjà expliqué pourquoi
chez Descartes
la liberté est un présupposé
pour Descartes l'homme possède un libre arbitre, c'est à dire une capacité à choisir
le libre arbitre chez descartes
c'est ce qu'il appelle le décret de l'âme
c'est à dire
la capacité et qu'a notre volonté
de se déterminer
Indépendamment des influences extérieures
Le libre arbitre c'est l'indépendance de la volonté vis-à-vis de la matière
Et le libre arbitre est fondamentalement lié
à cette distinction entre le corps et l'esprit
parce que pour qu'il y ait liberté
il faut qu'il y ait possibilité pour l'esprit
de se déterminer
indépendamment du corps
Voilà pourquoi le monisme de Spinoza fait directement obstacle à la notion de libre arbitre
Pourquoi est-ce que le libre arbitre est une illusion? et bien parce que l'homme
parce qu'il est à la fois un être physique et un être spirituel
c'est à dire un être doué d'une conscience
est bien l'homme pense qu'il est lui même
l'auteur de ses actes
L'auteur de ses actes c'est à dire le libre décideur de sa manière d'agir
et d'ailleurs c'est quelque chose sur quoi se fonde la plupart de nos sociétés modernes
c'est l'idée que nous sommes maîtres de notre corps
et c'est ce qui induit la notion de responsabilité
si nous ne possédions pas de libre arbitre
la notion de responsabilité n'existerait pas
et donc la notion même de justice au sens juridique du terme
n'aurait pas lieu d'être
un tueur pourrait très bien dire que c'est son corps qui a agit
et que sa volonté n'a fait que suivre le mouvement de son corps
que donc il n'ya pas lieu
de le désigner comme coupable
Si le libre orbite n'existe pas ça signifie que tout est justifiable
et ça c'est quelque chose
d'absolument révolutionnaire au sens strict du terme
c'est à dire que c'est quelque chose qui remettrait complètement en question les fondements mêmes de notre vie sociale
Imaginez par exemple que
celui qui vous a trahi, celui qui vous a blessé, celui qui vous a menti
pouvait se protéger derrière l'abri du monisme Spinozien en disant mais après tout
je ne suis pas responsable de ce que je fais
je suis entièrement déterminé
donc je ne peux pas me tenir
coupable
de ce que je fais de préjudiciable pour toi
Donc la vision de Spinoza n'est pas viable sur le plan juridico-politique
Et pourtant
elle met le doigt sur quelque chose d'absolument fondamental
qui est que
tout bien considéré
sommes nous vraiment les auteurs de nos actes?
sommes nous vraiment
les responsables de ce que nous pensons et de ce que nous faisons?
Alors je dis de ce que nous pensons et de ce que nous faisons parce que
comme je l'ai déjà dit pour Spinoza
il n'y a pas de différence fondamentale
entre la pensée et la matière
Spinoza a cette citation assez connu :
"l'ordre et la connexion des idées sont les mêmes que l'ordre et la connexion des choses"
ce qui signifie que nos actes ne sont que la conséquence mécanique de nos idées
de même que nos idées ne sont que la conséquence mécanique de nos actes
C'est très déroutant comme manière de voir les choses parce que nous avons toujours tendance à instaurer une antériorité
entre la pensée et l'action
l'idée que
l'action serait déterminée par notre pensée ou au contraire l'idée que notre pensée serait
déterminée par nos actions
et pour Spinoza
c'est une mauvaise manière de voir les choses
c'est ne pas comprendre comment fonctionne l'être humain et comment fonctionne l'interaction entre le corps et l'esprit
Vous remarquerez que très souvent
lorsqu'on est placé dans des conditions matérielles différentes
bien on peut avoir des opinions différentes
et de la même façon lorsque nos opinions évoluent
ça se répercute dans notre manière d'agir et donc dans nos conditions matérielles d'existence
La vision que proposait Descartes, c'est à dire l'idée que l'être humain était guidé par son libre arbitre
c'est en réalité la vision chrétienne puisqu'on la trouve chez saint-augustin
qui disait que
dieu avait doté l'homme du libre arbitre
et que par conséquent vous pouvez pas attribué à dieu la responsabilité du mal sur terre
C'est parce que l'homme possède le libre arbitre qu'il a le choix de faire le bien ou de faire le mal
et c'est ce qui faisait dire justement à Descartes que
l'être humain était le seul être en sur terre
qui était doué de ce libre arbitre
puisque
les objets inanimés n'ont pas d'âme par définition
donc ils n'ont pas de volonté
donc ils n'ont pas de libre arbitre
Si je prends ce stylo qui devant moi et que je le lance à travers la pièce
le stylo n'a pas le choix de sa trajectoire
Sa trajectoire
sera le résultat mécanique
de la direction et de la force
avec laquelle je l'aurais lancé
il n'a pas le choix le stylo
de même pour Descartes l'animal ne possède pas le libre arbitre
C'est d'ailleurs de là que vient sa théorie de l'animal machine
Lorsque Descartes disait que les animaux étaient des machines évidemment
il ne voulait pas dire que les animaux étaient composés
de métal, de ferraille ou je ne sais quoi
pas du tout
il voulait simplement dire que les animaux
obéissaient à quelque chose qu'on appelle l'instinct
et dans lequel la notion de volonté n'intervient absolument pas
tout simplement parce que l'animal n'a pas conscience de son instinct
L'homme serait le seul à posséder le libre arbitre parce qu'il a conscience
de ce qui l'anime, il a conscience
de son désir
les animaux sont des machines parce qu'ils agissent mécaniquement
parce qu'ils agissent
sans conscience donc sans volonté
alors que les hommes
lorsqu'ils agissent
sont poussés par une conscience
qui fait qu'on peut pas les réduire à des objets inanimés, à des animaux, c'est à dire
qu'on peut pas les réduire à leur dimension purement physique et matérielle
Et dans une certaine mesure c'est vrai
l'homme n'est pas obligé de se plier
aux contraintes extérieures, il n'est pas obligé de se plier aux influences multiples qu'il reçoit
il a cette capacité de dire non
Mais pour Spinoza
ce n'est pas suffisant parce qu'en réalité
ce libre arbitre humain
c'est d'abord une illusion
une illusion qui vient du fait que l'homme
n'a pas conscience
de ce qui est à l'origine
de ses désirs ou de ses pensées
L'homme a bien conscience qu'il peut décider
mais il n'a pas conscience
de l'historique des causes et des effets
qui l'amène à faire un certain choix
à tel moment dans telle situation
Là encore je vais prendre un exemple
Imaginons vous êtes tranquillement installé sur votre canapé en train de regarder un film
que tout à coup vous avez envie d'aller dans votre réfrigérateur pour prendre un yaourt
vous allez vous lever, vous allez chercher votre yaourt
et puis vous allez le manger en éprouvant un certain plaisir en vous disant que
c'est quand même pas mal d'être un être humain parce que
on peut faire des choses qu'on choisit
Et Spinoza répond que à ce moment là
vous oubliez que
il y a un certain nombre de raisons
il y a un certain nombre de facteurs
qui vous ont poussé à aller jusqu'à votre réfrigérateur pour prendre un yaourt
Toutes ces raisons on n'en a pas conscience
et pourtant elles existent
Ce que veut dire Spinoza c'est que
certes nous avons le pouvoir de choisir
mais nous n'avons pas le pouvoir de choisir
les raisons qui nous poussent à choisir
Notre choix n'est en fait qu'un choix de surface
Notre choix repose sur le pur constat d'un désir, d'une affection
c'est à dire d'une envie, d'une émotion, d'une passion
Et ces passions
ce n'est pas nous qui les choisissons
Nous ne choisissons pas nos passions, nous ne choisissons pas nos désirs,  nous les subissons
nous les subissons comme le stylo subi l'impulsion que je vais lui faire subir
et qui va l'amener à emprunter telle direction
sans avoir la possibilité
de résister
De ce point de vue là pour Spinoza nous sommes prisonniers de ce qu'il appelle le déterminisme
Le Déterminisme c'est l'idée que
dans un monde physique
tout est soumis à la loi de la causalité
toute cause produit un effet qui devient à son tour la cause d'un effet suivant
et ainsi de suite à l'infini
Qu'est ce qui fait qu'on a envie d'un yaourt
c'est peut-être parce qu'on aura vu passer une publicité pour un yaourt quelques minutes avant le film
et que cette vision
aura pénétré notre corps et notre esprit
à un niveau infra-conscient
et à un moment donné va faire naître cette envie
Alors je prends cet exemple mais il y en aurait une infinité d'autres
prenons l'exemple
de l'élève de terminale qui passe son bac et qui décide de s'inscrire en fac de biologie
C'est un libre choix
il s'inscrit en fac de biologie comme il aurait pu s'inscrire en fac de droit ou en école de commerce
mais il a choisi la fac de biologie
c'est son choix
Mais qu'est ce qui a motivé ce choix
qu'est ce qui a déterminé ce choix
ça peut être parce peu cet élève aura grandi dans une famille de scientifiques
qu'ils lui auront transmis le goût de la science, le goût de l'étude du corps humain
et qui aura fait que sans même s'en rendre compte cette élève aura choisi la voie de la biologie
en étant fondamentalement convaincu que c'est son choix
et d'un point de vue purement subjectif
c'est vrai
d'un point de vue purement subjectif ce choix ne pas être vécue comme une obligation
ou une détermination quelconque
Ce choix sera vécu comme relevant d'une libre décision
Et pourtant ce choix aura des causes
ce choix
sera le résultat
d'un enchaînement de causes et d'effets
qui l'auront conduit à faire ce choix
Et tout ce qu'on fait dans notre vie n'échappe pas à cette règle de la causalité
Parce que l'être humain est un être physique
l'être humain est un être matériel
et en tant qu'être matériel
il est soumis aux lois de la matière
il ne peut pas s'y soustraire
il ne pas y échapper
L'être humain en tant qu'être physique est soumis aux lois physiques
Si vous décidez de vous jeter de votre balcon pour essayer de vous envoler
les lois physiques
vont vous rappeler à l'ordre
elles vont vous dire tu ne peux pas
tu n'as pas cette liberté
parce que la liberté s'inscrit toujours à l'intérieur d'un ensemble de contraintes physiques
Ce serait comme de vouloir faire des crêpes
sans utiliser d’œufs, sans utiliser de farine
ça n'a aucun sens
Si tu veux faire des crêpes tu vas suivre une recette
et si tu ne suis pas la recette
tu ne va pas pouvoir faire des crêpes
donc
une réalisation dans le monde physique
présuppose l'obéissance un certain nombre de règles
ça nous paraît évident mais
ce n'est pas évident
ce n'est pas évident parce que au quotidien
c'est très fréquent qu'on se comporte en oubliant les lois fondamentales de la matière
Prenez l'exemple des dominos qui tombent en cascade
lorsqu'on pousse le premier
on est bien d'accord
que lorsqu'on pousse le premier domino
la chute du dernier domino
n'est que la conséquence logique et mécanique de la chute du premier
Et pourtant
dans la plupart de nos agissements
nous ne faisons pas la relation entre notre action
et l'effet final de notre action
la conséquence ultime de notre action
parce que nous sommes focalisés uniquement sur
la conséquence immédiate de notre action
un peu comme une mouche qui s'obstinent à taper le carreau de la fenêtre
sans voir que la fenêtre est ouverte
Nous sommes dans cette espèce d'enfermement
mental, intellectuel
qui nous empêche de voir
l'enchaînement des causes et des effets dans lequel nous nous inscrivons
Et c'est cet aveuglement, cet aveuglement à la causalité
Qui fait dire à Spinoza que le libre arbitre est une illusion
Il prend une métaphore extrêmement simple à comprendre qui est la métaphore de la pierre que l'on lance sur le sol
Si vous prenez une pierre et que vous la lancez sur le sol, sa trajectoire sera défini par la manière dont vous l'aurez lancé
Mais imaginez que au moment où vous lâchez la pierre sur le sol
celle ci se retrouve doué de conscience
Qu'est ce qu'elle va se dire la pierre?
et bien elle va se dire
qu'elle est elle même la cause de son mouvement
que c'est elle qui décide de là où elle va
Elle ne va pas se dire que sa trajectoire a été déterminé par un élément extérieur
Et bien pour Spinoza nous sommes dans la même situation que cette pierre
ou subissons des mouvements
qui proviennent de l'extérieur
et nous nous plaisons à croire
que nous sommes la cause de ces mouvements
Pour Spinoza
le libre arbitre est une illusion
aussi longtemps que l'on pense être la cause de nos agissements
De nos agissements et de nos pensées parce que pour Spinoza ces deux choses sont indissociables
Alors évidemment la question qui se pose
après tout ça c'est de se dire mais alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire?
est ce que ça veut dire
que l'homme n'est finalement pas supérieur à une pierre ou un animal?
Qu'il est tout autant soumis aux déterminations du monde extérieur et qui n'a pas son mot à dire?
Est ce que ça veut dire que nous serions finalement prisonnier d'une illusion fondamentale
d'un péché d'orgueil qui nous ferait croire que nous sommes libres, libres de nos actions, libres de nos pensées
mais qu'en réalité tout ça ne serait que chimère
Et bien pas totalement
Et c'est là que vous et apporter un correctif
Par rapport à une interprétation commune
de la pensée de Spinoza sur la question de la liberté et du déterminisme
Il est de bon ton
de convoquer Spinoza pour expliquer que l'homme n'est pas plus libre que la pierre qu'on lance
que l'animal qui obéit à son instinct
il est de bon ton de dire que l'idée de la liberté n'est qu'une illusion philosophique
qui ne repose sur rien, sur rien d'autre que l'ignorance des causes qui nous déterminent
ok
Mais alors il faut aller au bout de la démarche et comprendre ce que Spinoza essayé de nous dire
ce qui suppose pour cela
d'être allé au bout de la lecture de l'éthique
Je rappellerai ici que comme le disait Gilles Deleuze
si le livre de Spinoza s'appelle "Ethique"
c'est qu'il repose sur l'idée que l'homme a le choix
parce que l'éthique n'a de sens que pour des individus
possédant un pouvoir
de détermination sur eux mêmes
Deleuze disais que
si la pensée de Spinoza n'était qu'une
description
de l'illusion du libre arbitre, d'une description
de l'enchaînement des causes et des effets, le terme d'éthique n'aurait pas lieu d'être
il aurait dû alors parler d'ontologie, c'est-à-dire de l'étude de l'être, l'étude de ce qui est
pourtant Spinoza parle d'éthique, c'est à dire du'une pensée dirigée vers l'action
l'éthique c'est la pensée tourné vers l'action
Et si l'être humain n'avait pas le pouvoir de déterminer son action
il n'y aurait tout simplement
pas lieu de parler d'éthique
Autrement dit
pour Spinoza
la liberté est possible
la liberté existe
Alors la question de savoir comment atteindre cette liberté
Mais en fait Spinoza nous donne la réponse
Il nous explique
que l'être humain
parce qu'il possède une conscience
est capable de prendre conscience de ce qui le détermine
il est capable de se rendre compte
qu'il subit des influences
qui vont orienter ses choix et ses actions
Et cette conscience qu'il appelle la raison
elle fait toute la différence
car c'est par la raison que l'homme accède à la liberté
Alors là il faut un petit peu expliquer les choses en détails parce que
c'est une notion qui n'est pas claire pour tout le monde
la raison chez Spinoza ce n'est pas simplement la faculté de comprendre que nous sommes déterminés
C'est d'abord la capacité de comprendre que nous sommes déterminés, mais déterminés par quoi?
Déterminés par des influences qui agissent sur nous et qui agissent plus particulièrement sur
nos passions
sur ce que Spinoza appelle nos affects
et qu'on traduirait aujourd'hui par le terme d'émotions
Nos émotions et j'ai eu l'occasion d'en parler dans ma vidéo sur le stoïcisme
à proprement parler nous ne les maîtrisons pas
elles nous arrivent, elles nous parviennent
nous les subissons
D'où le terme grec pathos pour parler des passions, les passions de l'âme
c'est à dire ce que notre âme subi
Prenons quelques exemples : l'inquiétude
c'est à dire la non quiétude
L'inquiétude est une passion
l'inquiétude est un affect
l'inquiétude est quelque chose que nous subissons
lorsque nous nous trouvons dans une situation
d'incertitude
mêlée à la peur
Notre conjoint qui devait rentrer à 18h et qui n'est toujours pas là 19h
alors il est possible que
ce conjoint et fait le choix
de faire un petit détour au bistrot pour partager un un petit moment de détente
avec ses amis
mais le fait est que si nous tentons de le joindre sur son portable et qu'il ne répond pas
l'inquiétude pourra apparaître à ce moment là
et que nous dit cette inquiétude
elle ne nous dit rien d'autre que l'ignorance
de la situation de notre conjoint
et cette ignorance cause en nous une peur
La peur qu'il lui soit arrivé quelque chose, la peur qu'il ait fait une mauvaise rencontre
la peur qu'ils soient en train de passer un moment joyeux avec quelqu'un d'autre que nous
Mais cette peur au fond
et elle rationnelle
Non
cette peur n'est pas rationnelle dans la mesure où cette peur n'apporte rien à la compréhension de la situation
Cette peur ne fait qu'apporter de la souffrance à la souffrance
elle ne résout rien
et là
vous aurez reconnu
un petit fragment de stoïcisme chez Spinoza il y a du stoïcisme  chez Spinoza
il ya du stoïcisme parce qu'il y à l'idée que
la passion nous asservie
et que la raison nous libère
et si vous êtes dans la raison
lorsque l'inquiétude vous assaille
et bien l'inquiétude
va s'évanouir
elle va disparaître
Parce que la passion se dissout sous la force de la raison
Qu'est ce qui fait que certaines personnes arrivent à gérer avec
décontraction, détente, des situations qui nous plongeraient dans l'inquiétude, dans la peur
Bien c'est tout simplement le travail en elle de la raison, c'est à dire de la conscience
La conscience que notre ressenti
n'apportera aucune modification à la situation
n'apportera aucune amélioration
Et c'est lorsqu'on admet que la passion ne change rien à la situation
qu'on entre dans la raison dans le temple de la raison
La raison qui nous dit que nous n'avons d'influence que sur ce qui dépend de nous par exemple
et si vous multipliez cet exemple
à tous les exemples possibles de situations où l'émotion prend le dessus
vous allez vous apercevoir que la raison à la un pouvoir magique
Elle a le pouvoir de faire disparaître
l'émotion, de faire disparaître le pathos, de  faire disparaître la souffrance
Et à ce moment là nous dit Spinoza
Vous allez connaître la joie
La joie qui n'est pas une émotion
La joie qui est une manière d'être
et qui consiste dans
la compréhension rationnelle de se quitter
Parce que dès lors que vous êtes animé par la joie
autrement dit dès lors que vous êtes animé par la raison
la raison qui fait s'évanouir, toute passion toute affection
Bien à ce moment là tout ce que vous allez faire
vous allez le faire de manière libre
Je sais que c'est quelque chose qui est difficile à conceptualiser
Parce que c'est d'abord quelque chose qui s'expérimente
mais l'action dans la joie
c'est l'action dans la conscience que ce qui est ne peut être que ce qui est
et dans cette acceptation se produit quelque chose d'absolument phénoménal
Qui est la joie intense de l'être
la joie intense
de ce qui est
et la pleine conscience
de notre pouvoir
notre pouvoir d'agir, notre pouvoir de penser, notre pouvoir d'être
La liberté existe chez Spinoza
parce que la liberté n'est pas un pouvoir d'indétermination
ce n'est pas le pouvoir de s'extraire des déterminations physique
C'est le pouvoir de comprendre que tout est déterminé
Et que partant de là il est possible de comprendre tout ce qui est
Et agir en comprenant tout ce qui est c'est agir librement
c'est vraiment quelque chose sur quoi il faut insister
la liberté chez Spinoza est liée à la raison, c'est à dire au pouvoir de compréhension de ce qui est
vous n'êtes pas libre de faire en sorte que deux plus deux égale cinq
Vous n'êtes pas libres
vous êtes obligés de l'accepter
Mais est ce que cet acceptation est douloureuse pour vous?
est ce que cette acceptation est un sacrifice?
est ce qu elle est coûteuse pour vous?
non
elle n'est pas coûteuse tout simplement parce qu'elle n'amoindrit en rien ce que vous êtes
parce qu'elles ne touchent pas votre orgueil
votre estime de vous même
elle n'atteint pas vos passions
elle n'atteint pas vos affections
Vous êtes donc d'accord pour dire qu'accepter que deux plus deux égale quatre
c'est finalement se donner plus de liberté que de croire que deux plus deux égale cinq
Parce que si vous croyez que deux plus deux égale cinq, bien d'une manière ou d'une autre ça va vous poser problème dans la vie
vous n'êtes pas libre de faire en sorte que
le théorème de Pythagore ne soit pas valable
vous n'êtes pas libre de faire en sorte que la gravité disparaisse
vous composer avec
vous l'acceptez la gravité
comme vous accepter l'idée de la mort
Vous acceptez qu'un jour ou l'autre vous allez passer l'arme à gauche et que c'est dans l'ordre des choses
dans l'ordre et la connexion des choses
Pourtant c'est une idée que vous pouvez rejeter
Mais qu'est ce qu'ils rejettent cette idée
Là encore c'est l'ego, c'est l'orgueil, c'est la peur
ce sont des passions
La raison consisterait à accepter l'idée de la mort
non pas à la souhaiter, non pas à vouloir la précipiter
Mais à l'accepter comme données rationnelle du monde physique
Et si vous acceptez cette idée au plus profond de vous
si vous l'intérioriser à tel point que cette idée ne cause plus en vous de peur
bien ce moment là vous n'êtes plus asservi à la peur de la mort
vous n'êtes plus asservi à tout ce qui découle
de la peur de la mort
La raison est libératrice
la raison vous libère de vos peurs
elle vous libère de vos passions, elle vous libère de tout ce qui vous fait refuser le réel
Parce qu'on est quand même très fort pour refuser ceux qui paient
on est très fort
pour trouver des responsables ou des coupables
à notre propre incapacité à accepter ce qui est
être Spinozien
comme être stoïcien
ce n'est pas être fataliste
ce n'est pas renoncer, ce n'est pas se résigner
c'est comprendre que ce qui est
a des raisons d'être, a des causes d'être
et qu'on ne peut pas s'opposer aux causes
on ne peut ne pas s'opposer
à ce qui régit notre monde physique
en revanche
on peut comprendre ce qui régit notre monde physique
et comprendre qui signifie étymologiquement avoir en soi
comprendre c'est accepter
comprendre c'est enregistrer
alors lorsqu'on comprend quelque chose on s'allège, on franchi un pas vers la liberté
L'homme libre
est celui qui par un travail de la raison
n'est plus soumis à ses passions
Libre est l'homme qu'il agit conformément à la raison
car en comprenant la série des causes et des effets
l'homme peut s'extraire de ses passions
il peut s'extraire de ce que les lois de la matière lui font subir
Car si vous n'étiez qu'un être physique
le moindre événement extérieur pourrait produire sur vous une passion vous n'avez pas décidé d'éprouver
Le stylo
ne peut pas empêcher la trajectoire que je lui fait subir
en revanche vous qui m'écoutez
vous avez le pouvoir
de ne pas recevoir les passions du monde extérieur
de ne pas recevoir
les émotions
liées à ce qui vous arrive
de ne pas être asservi par vos passions
vous avez le pouvoir
de le comprendre, de le mettre à distance
de le poser à plat devant vous
et de comprendre le principe de leur formation
le processus par lequel ces passions
son entrée en vous
vous avez ce pouvoir
et vous allez constater
lorsque vous comprenez ce processus
parce que vous comprenez
comment est née l'émotion que vous ressentez actuellement
comment s'est formée l'inquiétude
qu'elle est la cause de cette peur qui vous accompagne
qui vous alourdis
de comprendre que tout ça n'est qu'un enchaînement de causes et d'effets
que vous n'êtes pas obligé de subir
comme si vous n'étiez que des réceptacles
vous avez un pouvoir
c'est le pouvoir de la raison et il ne tient qu'à vous de l'exercer
Je vous remercie